[Music]
I live in Studio City California and I
have three amazing boys bro look at this
guy
this guy using voice I don't think any
of my sons realize that I have an
extremely high libido hold on oh that's
so not too much saying I have an
extremely high libido should I just said
hi libido that's
you can't your kids don't need to know
that that's private nobody needs to
nobody is private one did we become this
thing where everyone is just like has to
like like flaunt their preferences and
their their hormonal rushes for the
world to see we're doomed I mean like
stuff [__] listen I raised you guys
change your diapers cleaned up after you
made you lunch every day taught you how
to drive and now it's time for mommy to
get her nut again and for you to find
out that I love to do it all the time
also by the way one of the things about
the show is that the the guys are all
younger so it's MILF stating younger
guys you know all around the same age as
all these woman's Sons would be but that
probably has nothing to do with the
shots right now I'll cut it that would
be that would be weird
that would be like being a rapist
um I am 50 years old
when I'm meeting good looking my type of
a man I introduced myself say hey I'm so
young and I'm so
I watched that like 10 times to figure
out what you said in the censored part
like just lip reading I think she says
hi I'm so young and I'm so wet oh my God
which is
which is [__] intense that's a little
bit aggressive for an opening line is it
not to be like a dude opening with
what's up what's up yeah my name is so
Chad and I'm so hard right now
wait hold on let me fix this dude I
don't need
this
sucks to watch like this sucks I'm Kelly
I'm 50 years old and my Alter Ego is
Disco mommy disco Mommy
[Music]
are you hot ladies doing disco mommy
loves house music and disco mommy she's
really spontaneous she's just fun I have
six amazing kids three girls and three
damn she has like young kids too like
what happened here how did like this one
get hot and this one let's just keep
going
hey boys that's the number one question
people ask me like like if from the same
guy I'm like no why would I have six
kids from the same guy hello what do I
have to offer you know we're getting
older ladies we're not getting younger
even though we can think that we can do
things to make ourselves look younger
we're really not shots fired at Jessica
mommy yes she probably was very hot when
she was younger
um more in shape damn this show is
already so uncomfortable like there's so
much tension around the bar right now
already it's been so uninteresting and
shallow and I'm sure that that's part of
the show and I would like to think that
if I took the time to watch this that
there would be some more substance but
right now it's this is the most surface
[__] I've watched in years and years
because I don't watch this stuff other
dating shows are 22 year olds that are
that don't have any real thoughts you
know the only thing they're thinking is
like the world's awesome [__]
everyone is so nice and hot and bad
things don't exist so like let's have
unprotected sex but these women have
like life they know how [__] up
everything and everyone is and gets so
immediately like there's this judgment
and just analysis going on and just like
just realistic right off the bat like
yeah she was probably hot in her younger
days she has codependency issues for
sure she went through a bad divorce for
sure I can tell uh she coached here her
husband or do the predictions as you see
them okay
yeah and uh she is definitely [__]
her trainer it's got that going for
herself I have disco Mommy what's the
prediction on Disco Mommy I well I I
thought that she was a cheater because
she's just so thirsty for attention
that's just what I got from the picture
of the little Montage that they did of
her the best trainer in Orange County so
if you guys want to come she has the
best trainer in Orange County oh okay
there you go see who told you okay so
now the big reveal who are all these
strapping young Lads that all these
women will be dating over the coming
weeks let's find out
[Music]
that's my mom right there that's my mom
right there
oh my God I just thought straight to
possessed eyes and just stay there for a
couple of seconds and say what is this
there's no way they didn't know what
they were getting into well they went
into it we saw something that said that
they went into it knowing that there was
going to be multi-generational
interaction that they were open to
dating older women and these ladies were
open to dating younger men it sounds
like that obviously they didn't know
that they were getting onto the same
dating show that's disgusting I'm just
walking wait that's my mom right there
holy [__] that was the shocking twist
the only thing I imagine is if it was my
dad in that group like that is the most
horrifying thing in the entire world to
me I'm gonna be honest I'm thinking
first pick in the draft
firsthand who have like dudes who have
slept with the moms their mom's best
friend no yes and I think that is the
most despicable disgusting thing how uh
you know a woman could do that too
that's crazy with her friend's child
yeah that's like I don't understand yeah
that's like Purgatory you got an extra
long visit it's like it's like being an
aunt I mean there's there's a pedophilia
element to it and I don't care what
anybody says I think it's disgusting and
this is not that far from it no this is
as far as I'm concerned because now
these women are supposed to bond with
each other and then sleep with each
other's Sons this is disgusting I can't
wait to go to church on Sunday I can't I
can't because in that room none of these
people are there maybe this chick
wow thank God for that
obviously he's not going to go for his
mom but that statement even if he was
just misspeaking for a moment shows the
level of intelligence of the people that
will do this how much you think they got
like are they getting like at least a
bag to be on this show or are they just
just doing it what's a bag like a big
bag of money yeah I doubt it I doubt
they're probably getting like 10 grand
brokeys that's crazy older women are
very hot and I know I got the swag and I
got the game for them wow this is like
news to me
yes Mom yes dude this kid is way too
young to be on this show what if come on
TLC what's going on was he like a
[__] Junior in college these women
are 50 years old Joey nicely what's your
name I'm April April
how about you
but whenever I'm insane insane eye
contact holy [__] he just stared her
down bring a woman home oh that was
so cringy I just want to like hunch my
monitor that was so cringy I thought you
were just gonna say I just want to punch
my mom
no
it's all up to my mom whether I'm dating
her or not
I've been winning been winning but then
I started looking at these women and I
was like damn they are kind of beautiful
and then my mom's right there I was like
this guy just pisses me off I am here to
find a special connection and I hope my
mom also finds a special connections
but we might find the perfect love in
here we don't know about me I'm floored
by how uncomfortable you don't know
about me it's wild she thinks she's
gonna find the perfect love in that room
I don't know it's a
I mean is anybody really gonna find a
real relationship in this room obviously
not this is a this is a you know get
laid kind of show I'm just so
disappointed that they can find this
many people willing to do this surprised
you could find one person willing to do
this this is so sad Beyond me but I mean
I don't know
oh it's like that drunk kid at the bar
that hits on the girls and every single
one is looking at him like get away from
me and he can't take the hint it's like
that guy you gonna be 22 huh he's like
an actor he's so like he lays it on so
thick oh it's it's too much oh you're
the baby are you gonna be 22 right I'm
gonna be 20.
[Music]
Gabriel and I are both here because we
wanted to take this adventure it
literally fell in our lap from the
heavens and I can't I'm sorry can you
stop and just let me talk
why are you saying Heaven straight wait
what I said this did not come from the
heavens this came straight out of the
devil's Lair yeah like you have the
opportunity to go to dating show it's
like I've been waiting for this for
just let me talk you do it again can you
not say why are you saying Heavens
because that's what I'm saying I I'm my
own person but can you stop interrupting
me so dude what is my man wearing he's
nailing the 2019 e-boy aesthetic
I have twins do you three boys Gabriel's
a twin oh wow but they don't look alike
fraternity so you brought the ugly one
thanks
that was some
part of my French that was 20. look at
this chick look at this chick right now
ah your kid's ugly
that's wild imagine saying that to
somebody and they just you just laugh
he's actually that's not ugly he's
actually a good looking young man he
looks like the um he reminds me of the
Edward guy Robert Pattinson Edward from
the Twilight series The Pale vampire kid
yeah yeah he has that he looks he has
that same aesthetic they all find out
that they're all staying in the same
room as their sons and there's two runes
with hot tubs in them and their first
challenge is to figure out who gets when
when you're hooking up you hang a you
hang a a sock on the on the doorknob
outside to let your son know not to come
in because I'm having sex with one of
these other children I don't know I
didn't think that far into it ew hang on
why because that's where this is going
you can see where this is going you have
to share a room go ahead let's go
because you know if you're if you're
sharing a room with your own mother you
definitely want to make sure there's a
hot tub in there for sure so the guy's
all stand in a row with their shirts off
I want you you everyone
me sorry
[__] everyone bought me so annoying
that's his mom by the way that's his mom
the blindfold that's gotta be some like
this kid's gotta have some issues like
off camera he has to have some serious
issues with his mom acting like that
yeah there's no way I mean he's got to
hear it from his friends all the time
like if you like like just the woman no
just that just messes you up she's kind
of clownish and cheap and I hate to say
that because it's mean but it's that's
what I see you're calling disco mommy
cheap sure I guess she calls herself
disco Mommy and she's like 50. so of
course his friends aren't going to look
at her and take her as a serious woman
why wouldn't they the blindfold and you
have to go up and touch all of the young
men and figure out by touching their
chests and abs and shoulders which one
is their son no why didn't they just do
it the other way why don't they just
have the sons walk up and touch all the
mom's boobs and figure out which one
belongs to their mom but like why not
just just go all in why play it safe
MILF Manor this is this is Haram I don't
have a word I'm telling you you know
describe how this makes me feel you know
what's even more concerning is if one of
the moms touches the guy's tits and is
like oh this is my boy that's that's
even weirder oh my God she doesn't go
below the waist whenever she's groping
these guys because that that will be out
of line yeah mine you better not be
jacking me off
remember I'll be jacking me off and
jacking all the other guys off make sure
you don't jack me off Mom everything
about to come out of his mouth has been
just I'm just wrong I'm just wrong and
I'm just like you're welcome this is
your dad oh
look at the face right here I'm I I feel
I honestly
look at his face look at this kid's face
poor kid how do you use for it he didn't
even he he's been so cocky all the time
even he's surprised how are you you said
it come up here Mom
Mom can you take everyone 10 to it too
relapse I'm going to the
bathrooms up if Joey continues to [__]
block me this entire time he's going to
ruin the experience for me that's
[__] ridiculous that is ridiculous
that is Haram this this this lady needs
God I'm going to church right now she
does though her need for attention and
she would you know defend herself
against this and it's her prerogative to
be free and sleep with whoever she wants
and all that and she would get all high
and mighty as if it was high and mighty
to be this way but you know all of these
Pursuits that will bring her to zero
happiness oh I'm sure Jessica mommy's
happy inside this is worse than I bet
you do you think those kids she just got
knocked up or like she was in
relationships with the guys How could a
guy ever take her seriously
nice house it's crazy is that like disco
mommy might be like watching this I
doubt it I hope not because that's a
wild I don't want to insult her I just I
want yeah I want to help her I feel like
I need to take her and help her and save
her from this insanity and turn her into
a mother that her children can be proud
of you don't have to you don't have to
be a saint or rich or successful for
your children to be proud of you but to
be with your son in a room and basically
telling your room your son he's [__]
you is is just so base I don't even know
where I don't even know how to no jokes
foreign
I'm [__] blocking my mom because first
night no you've known him for six hours
you can't just immediately go into you
know I wanna like the kid that she's
trying to seduce doesn't even seem
interested no he doesn't seem interested
at all he seems like this [__] is like
repulsive that's repulsive he seems
repulsed when a girl comes on to you
that much it's like disgusting it's
actually disgusting to me I'm just be
honest she's drunk she's slowering she's
kicking her son out there are so many
turn offs in this situation but the kid
you can see his dilemma he's kind of
feeling like this is what I'm here to do
like there's cameras on him and he feels
like he's got to perform for the cameras
too you can see it you can see his ah I
told him if he any but if he had any
cojones because he if he wasn't money
and he had some more Inner Strength he
would just be like dude put your mom to
bed you know why he wouldn't he wouldn't
do it he's thinking he doesn't want to
do it because he doesn't want to be with
the freaking hoe that that he doesn't
want to be known that he's with the hoe
that everyone else has slept with that's
been with her for more than three hours
that will limit his options that will
limit his options I don't even like it
when a girl asks for like my number at a
bar I'm like who else like how many
numbers on the girl but you're right how
many numbers are you asking yeah it
depends on how it's done like if you
talk to him you talked to her for a long
time yeah obviously I'm saying no but if
she like like at some places she's like
oh my God can I have yours like out of
nowhere they'll just come up to me like
I have your Snapchat and I'm like I
don't have it if you're just gonna come
up to a guy and just like ask him that
like you're doing that to Mad guys and
that's so unattractive to me that's
unattractive am I crazy for that or is
that like is that valid for thinking
that you're not crazy all right let's
see this kid is definitely this guy's
Gonna Be A Champion stay home I think
he's going to be a changed man after
this night he might be less of an
[__] after this let's see
big feet person Cola has these feet that
I just want to like oil up and lather
and just massage and get real warm and
then paint her toenails maybe a color
like suck the acrylic off them toes and
shove in my mouth
when did when
why why would you ever say that on TV
when
when when does that become a thing that
you what was the question why do I
do turn-ons and preferences need to be
public you know that could be one of the
ones that you just you just keep all of
them other than like I'm a leg man or
I'm a boob man like that should be like
and that's like that in my generation
like if somebody wanted that it was like
haha all right that's enough that's it
nobody nobody ever went further than
that we didn't ever have that
conversation the deep dirty conversation
that this guy wants to suck that nail
polish off her toes and I love it about
her
she has the idea let's do yoga and wants
to do the airplane and I'm I'm so for it
oh
well that's the show and I'm just so
happy that disco mommy didn't tell one
of the other moms that she was gonna
[__] their son I get the fantasy sweet
tonight oh a different guy now you
actually don't ah Charming this is a
little bit too much for me I think that
was disgusting it was disturbing and
that made me sad that these people exist
not only that the people on the show
exist that the writers of the show The
Producers of the show the executive
producers with their big fat checks to
produce the show all these unscrupulous
people who just have no limits
whatsoever yeah man I'm just I'm just
out of words right now I don't know what
to say the jokes the jokes tank is empty
the serious thoughts tank is empty I
honestly thought going into this video
that I was we were going to be making
fun and laughing and I just feel such a
disdain for society and such a
disappointment and so afraid the end is
near not near enough all right thank you
so much for watching make sure to like
subscribe and I'll see you later
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings